foreign
let's go to Holly and Kansas City
Missouri what's up Holly
hi Dr John how we doing
oh I'm so excited to talk to you I'm
excited to talk to you and Patrick
Mahomes way to go all right so what's up
um okay so my question for you is where
do you draw the line between your
responsibility to your spouse and your
responsibility to your kids
um and I can give you some context here
on that give me some context
but he's not a great dad
um 14 and 12. 14 and 12. and hey I I was
talking over the top of you and I
apologize you said something profound
say it again
I said he's a good husband but he's not
a great dad
unpack that for me
so he's well I feel very obligated to
stay at the offset like no abuse or
anything like that he's just very
emotionally unavailable okay
um maybe emotionally immature even
and
I feel like I have a responsibility to
him to help him grow into the best
person that he can be
um and I love him dearly but I feel like
I also have a responsibility to raise
boys who will be good Dads and if they
model off of him I don't think that will
be
um successful so you can't help him be
better he has to choose to be better
you can assist him you can walk
alongside him you can help meet his
needs if he is of the emotional maturity
to speak them out loud and he has a
vested interest in also meeting your
needs you can do that
um you can't help him be the best dad he
can be he has to choose that he wants to
be a better dad
when you've brought this up to him in
the past how has he responded
families are and I get jealous of oh
that's Dangerous Ground Holly
that's super Dangerous Ground
um because in Reverse him saying
um man I see how other wives take care
of themselves I just some gel like you
write you see how that can get real
sideways real fast so give me some
examples let's take other people's lives
off the table because no matter what you
think you're just getting a curated
version of that world
what are some things that you see in
your life that you think make him not a
good dad
he doesn't play with our kids he has
never really played with our kids he
really kind of
only interacts with him to like give
them chores or something like that it's
not a
like it's almost a sequence spoken to
not really trying to make them into the
adults he wants them to be more of
enforce the children he wants to have
okay so he's more concerned with don't
bother me stay out of my way I can give
you your life and I give you food in a
bed get away see what you're told don't
ask questions if I say no I say no that
sort of stuff okay and he doesn't take
them those those kind of speak when
spoken to you do what I say those type
of
that type of parenting only works in a
relationship right when there's a
context there
um do they miss their dad do they even
try to interact with them or they just
moved on
they just moved on they come to me for
things or like they'll ask me to ask him
questions but I don't think he knows
that they do that
so hard question for you
where was this conversation 12 years ago
it wasn't as bad then okay
um it just seems like it's gotten worse
and worse as time goes on does he not
like them do they just did they freak
him out do they scare him what's he
what's he trying to protect himself from
I think
he doesn't I I think that's more of an
inward thing than an outward thing what
does that mean like I think he doesn't
like himself
okay and so because of that he just
Retreats further and further into
himself how's your marriage
um you know we're going we're working on
some stuff like I think most people are
that was a that was not even a good
evasive answer how's your marriage
Teddy's a great husband I'm calling BS
no he he
for me
um so he'll change your tire he'll
change your tire that's cool and he
makes sure the oils change which is
awesome and he does pay bills cool
um is that the standard by which we were
saying he's a great husband now
um well he's really starting to put in
some effort to become not just the
husband he wants to be but the husband I
need and I respect that and in giving
him time to you know rise to the
excision okay
um you have bifurcated a man into two
different roles
he's a husband over here and he's a dad
over here
I would say those are relationships
that emanate from the same person
and in many ways those can be different
skill sets and different different tools
that I've got to pick up along the way
and learn right I've never parented a 12
year old before in my house and so I'm
having to learn in real time what that
what that's like
um but it's worth the effort right I've
never I've never parented a six-year-old
girl and good God Almighty I don't know
what I'm doing and but I'm giving it my
best shot from reading and learning and
talking to wise people and saying I'm
sorry and asking for advice and wisdom
right and more most above all else I'm
leaning into that relationship is weird
and awkward as both of them can be
your husband isn't a great dad and a bad
husband or a bad husband and a great dad
um he's a man who's really struggling
and he might perform better on one task
and he's not performing well on the
other but he may be
trying to get better in one relationship
but abandoning other relationships this
comes from the same guy
and I say that because if he got the
parent the husbanding thing down great
and he's a completely neglects his kids
he's never going to be there right
you're never going to fully lean into
that
you shouldn't right so
man this is hard because I know he I can
almost guarantee you he would have a
another side of the story
um
well that's why I guess my question is I
I don't really know
when
how do you choose or when do you face a
line where you have to choose because
I've heard callers call into your show
before and say things like I wish I
would have done something differently I
just don't want to be in a position that
I wish I would have done something
sooner or later to have you know that's
a great great question
um and I'm trying to be sensitive to my
own home and keep some space between
intensely private things in my house and
also be open
um I can tell you over the last 12 years
with both of my kids there's been
Seasons when my wife will say to me or I
will say to her
um this I would like to see this
different with our kid
and both of us have enough trust with it
with one another that we can at least
have
um I trust that you're right or I trust
at least it's worth another conversation
or I can say things like I don't like
where this the state of y'all's
relationship I'm gonna lean in for a
while and I'm gonna take this for a
season because your knees just needs to
be some space here
um and vice versa right and so
um that's that's as that's as much as I
want to get into it without going into
too many details and none of it's bad or
salicious it's just us leaning on each
other and being willing to speak truth
to each other and so if I'm you
I would take my like the same advice I
give her but I'll take him out and say
listen
um
you're losing your sons
and there's few things in the world more
important than a son's relationship to
his dad
your sons will chase his Blessing for
their entire life even if they hate him
they are desperate for him to hug them
they are desperate for them for him to
put his hands on the back of their neck
or hold their face and look him in the
eye and say I love you I'm glad you're
my son
they are desperate for that so desperate
that they will seek that in a million
different places
and they will chase and Chase and Chase
and Chase until their world is Ash
and I would speak that directly to him
and what it looks like is something as
simple as my son Hank and I go to
breakfast at Waffle House once a week
I do bedtimes with both my kids every
night
I treat their mother really well
I take my son with me places I try my
daughter doesn't like to always leave
the house but uh I I take them
everywhere I took my daughter to the
store with me the other day I take my
son with me places
I intentionally build in some time
because when you take a kid to the store
it takes another 45 minutes
and when I take my son fishing we're
gonna catch less fish all right because
I'm going to be untangling things and
whatever
um and so I'm just building it into my
life because
I love my kids and like you mentioned
you said it perfectly I'm raising young
adults right I've got a finite amount of
time and influence and but it's not even
about that it's about I love them and I
like spending time with them I would
have that conversation with your husband
in a very direct way
this needs to change
and what you have to be prepared for is
him to say no it's not going to
I don't like them they annoy me I don't
want them around me I don't know what
I'm doing
and he's gonna has a he has a right to
opt out
that becomes a pretty tough character
issue but you've got to here's what I'm
saying you can't be a peacemaker anymore
you've got to put it on the line and say
something
and to answer your original question
um you always always always
protect the kids always that's one of my
core value rules when it comes to
working in these kind of situations kids
come first
thank you
you got real quiet on me no it's just a
lot to take in
um I think take me to that conversation
conversation why
yeah
because it I don't think it'll go over
well
because I don't well no I know that he
doesn't see a problem like whenever I've
told him before hey the you know one kid
has come to me and asked me to talk to
you about this one thing for them
because they're scared to or you know
they weren't comfortable with it like it
kind of brushes that off if that's silly
there's no reason they should feel
uncomfortable and that's where you stop
and say but they do
and they do because you don't ever talk
to them you never take them places you
have no input in their life other than
to make sure they're doing the things
that you said
the last time you hugged them and said I
love you I'm so grateful that out of all
the people in the world I got picked to
be your dad
you've said that zero times
that's why
and I'm just telling you right now
here's here's my promise to you Holly my
promise is this
avoiding this conversation is choosing
to pick
the illusion of stability
over the heartfelt reality that you
fought for your sons
when nobody else would
and I also am not naive
I know that some of these conversations
end very badly
but what I would tell you is that ending
will come sooner or later
whether you have this conversation or
not so you might as well have it
you'll want to be able to look at your
sons at some point if their dad abandons
them and say I went down swinging for
you guys
because you all deserve to have a dad
and he was struggling it wasn't y'all's
fault
I recommend doing this right to write
down what you want to say and be very
specific
don't say things like I feel and I feel
like that feelings are great and they're
important but they're easily dismissed
in these kind of conversations be very
specific
you haven't I haven't seen the boys are
desperate for they're avoiding you
they're scared of you here's the context
we've built and here's a couple of
things I'm asking you to start doing
tell our boys you love them every
freaking day
stop what you're doing close your
computer put your phone down and hug our
sons every day
every day ask them
what's the best part of your day
once a week take each one of them out to
breakfast you can do that once a week
take each one of them on a walk you can
do that
and my hope is maybe just doesn't know
maybe he thinks they don't like him
maybe he's never seen this happen and
this is all weird and new because his
dad didn't talk to him fine
he's got to make a change or he's about
to lose his two boys
uh 12 and a 14 year old about to head
off into the woods without him
if they haven't already
thank you for loving them this is where
that love gets real hard
but they're lucky to have you as their
mom Holly